von der spitze des stifters stürzt sich
der deutsche freeskier benedikt mayer
ins tal rasant überwindet er 550
höhenmeter
gemeinsam mit seinem südtiroler freund
markus eder mit akrobatischen tricks
überqueren sie die passstrasse insgesamt
19 mal
die dreharbeiten fanden bereits im
sommer statt
das video über die spektakuläre abfahrt
hat er gerade veröffentlicht
das schwierige war dass es so unfassbar
stall mir so wenig schnee hatten dh
da war kein spielraum für fehler man
musste immer perfekt landen und gleich
den nächsten schwung ansetzen weil sonst
ja man einfach ins tor ein und
bergabwärts gerollt die fahrt war drei
minuten die vorbereitung mit zwei jahren
allein den schnee mit baggern und raupen
so zu präparieren dass eine abfahrt auch
hier möglich ist dauert mehrere monate
das stets jedoch der mehr als 2750 meter
uralten passt der die lombardei und den
vinschgau in südtirol verbindet ist der
höchste gebirgspass italiens und eine
der extremsten straßen der welt
er war bei der fahrt oben immer total
schlecht durch die ganzen kern und
irgendwie ist man im kopf geblieben
diese straße
man habe mich dann muss man irgendwann
mal noch mal was machen diese
herausforderung auf diesem extrem und
herrschaft der 29-jährige nur weil er
über jahrzehnte viele unterschiedliche
erfahrungen im schnee gesammelt hat
schon als kind bewegte sich trickreich
über die pisten und entwickelt sich zu
einem der besten freeskier europas 2014
tritt benedikt mayer bei den olympischen
winterspielen in der neuen disziplin
slopestyle an
als einziger deutscher
[Musik]
das einzige was vorgegeben ist war der
kurs und du kannst dich aber komplett
selber frei entfalten also du kannst
selber in der hand welche tricks du
machst du links rechts rum kopfüber
nicht kopfüber drehst und ja sie sind
sehr kreativer sport durch das regelwerk
des neuen olympischen trendsports fühlt
er sich bald eingeengt und findet seine
freiheit in island und alaska wieder
beim freeriden durch unberührten schnee
abseits der markierten skipiste
[Musik]
so ganz oben auf dem berg alleine schon
etwas besonderes also du weißt dass so
eine abfahrt die gibt es wahrscheinlich
nur hier in alaska zum beispiel und das
ist ja sehr sehr aufregend
angsteinflößend auch zum teil weil die
berge einfach sehr mächtig sind aber die
angst auch positiv zu steuern für sich
zu nutzen und zu sagen geber nicht ewig
merke da habe ich jetzt angst davor aber
ich schau mal was probieren und sonst
wird es ja jeder machen also angst es
immer noch
benedikt mayer macht es spaß die grenzen
des skisports immer wieder neu
auszuloten
immer wieder denkt er sich neue und
extreme reformen aus sich durch den
schnee zu bewegen und dokumentiert das
entnehmen
[Musik]
man werde er niemals dasselbe machen die
fantasie bei dem sport ist essentiell
ohne die kann nichts entstehen und
daraus entstehen neue tricks neue
sprünge
jeder mensch sieht der garten dass
wieder einmal das steht ja auch projekte
am anfang nur eine idee im kopf und man
musste sich vorstellen wie so was auch
schon könnte dann bringt man es mal zu
papier
ja und da steht man dann da und das ist
wirklichkeit und da muss man drauf waren
eine fahrt mit skiern über das
stilfserjoch ist bisher einmalig und
sicher ein höhepunkt in venedig meyers
bisheriger sportlicher karriere
doch vor allem hat ihm die ungewöhnliche
fahrt viele neue ideen geliefert für
neue abenteuer im schnee
[Musik]